j'ai hâte de vous entends j'ai toujours
hâte de vous entendre mais j'ai hâte
particulièrement de vous en tant que ce
soit ça tombe bien le du temps
chantal hébert michel david jonathan
trudeau bon choix
je vous montre le candidat
sauf patrick brown qui est plus pâle qui
n'est pas encore officiellement candidat
le maire de brampton monsieur babeurre
que vous entendrez peut-être moins
parler mais y est officiellement
candidat madame lewis qui retente sa
chance et bien sûr les deux qui vont
s'affronter jean charest monsieur
poilievre
si je vous montre rapidement un sondage
journal de montréal et j'ai de ce matin
les gens vont dire bon bah c'est réglé
mais attention ça c'était avant qu'il se
déclare fait je vous pose la question là
on voit poilievre dans l'état actuel des
choses et une nette avance bon monsieur
mekehout pense même qu'il va donner son
appui à charron vers un chantage
commence avec vous il faut pas prendre
ce sondage là comme étant immobile au
contraire
la course commence
la course commence et
les ces chiffres le monde quand même
quelque chose est ce que ça montre c'est
que si j'en change rien au sport et
patrick brown avec lui parce qu'ils sont
parents de deux frères siamois le haut
niveau de leurs places en deux parties
s'ils réussissent pas à recruter un
nombre important de nouveaux mondes
d'ici le 3 juin c'est bien et tout ça va
être très difficile de renverser la
vapeur de cette course là ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont pas réussi patrick
brown un organisateur hors pair il l'a
prouvé en ontario quand il s'est
présenté à la direction du parti en
ontario était député fédéral les gens
qui courir la colline parlementaire
fédéral on dit patrick blanc c'est qui
ça il ya gagné il n'y a pas gagné de
plus
et jean charest on sait au québec en
atlantique un avantage mais néanmoins on
va en savoir plus long sur 6 monsieur
charia vraiment de chance de l'emporter
quand on va avoir fini de recruter des
membres le 3 juin ce qui est demain
matin ce qui ce qui arrive très vite
michel david oui si le temps s'arrêtait
aujourd'hui avec les cartes actives
aujourd'hui
poilievre ce serait réglé michel oui
absolument mais quand chantal dit un
nombre important c'est un nombre très
important je pense que philippe fournier
dans sur son site le canada 3 traduite
par les 200 événements mais il faudrait
aller chercher 100 mille membres
25000 quatre pour que monsieur charest
100000 ccb du monde alors je me trouve
que la barre est très très hot et
d'autant plus que le grand argument de
des gens qui craignent un recentrage
avec raison d'ailleurs avec monsieur
charest se serait bon avec lui on
pourrait gagner alors là il ya le
sondage indique avec monsieur charest
pour le moment la campagne pour
commencer on est encore loin d'une
éventuelle élection mais pour le moment
les conservateurs ne font aucun gain
avec monsieur charest pour beaucoup
d'ailleurs avec monsieur poilievre mais
encore moins avec monsieur charest on
prend le sondage pour ce qu'il est ce à
dire une photographie maintenant mais il
reste que c'est un argument qui pendant
un moment monsieur charest pourra
difficilement évoqué oui il y aura
besoin éventuellement de sondages qui
montrent qu'ils feraient bien vis-à-vis
de bruit jonathan
c'est certain que la différence de 30
points dans le sondage léger ce matin
semblent immenses par contre lors on
peut apporter un bémol oui il ya le fait
que la campagne la course et le dé but
mais aussi c'est un sondage qui est fait
auprès de gens qui se disent des
sympathisants conservateurs qui seraient
appelés à voter pour les conservateurs
or le sondage final ce sont les membres
ceux qui auront des cartes de membres
qui voteront donc oui la pente elle est
raide mais peut-être connaissant jean
charest ce genre de défi qu'il ne
déteste pas de partir comme la personne
qui sous-estimé et chantal parler de
patrick bande qui va pouvoir réduit
aussi la
récolter des nouveaux membres n'oublions
pas tasha kheiriddin aussi qu'ils
étaient en train de mettre en place à
une organisation au cours des quatre
dernières semaines elles sont des deux
ne viendra pas au niveau du vote
préférentiel puisqu'elle s'est rallié
dès maintenant mais elles aussi vont
pouvoir aider jean charest a ratissé
large est loin d'être faits c'est loin
d'être fait en même temps faut pas non
plus prendre pour pour perdre un match à
bon
trois sujets dont je que je vais aborder
avec vous et je sais ce que c'est un
plus ou un moins ça dépend où vous allez
me dire sur le pétrole bon il en parle
il en a déjà parlé depuis quelques temps
il en a reparlé aujourd'hui à mario
dumont entre autres je l'écoutais ce
matin où il dit il faut pas attendre
d'avoir soif c'est l'expression qu'il
répète là pour pour creuser des puits
alors il dit je suis ouvert à des
oléoducs je suis ouvert à des projets
est ce à dire que gnl l'énergie est bon
qu'ils se tournant vers avec les
américains mais chantal le sujet du
pétrole est-ce que ça l'aide partout
oui et parce que les députés québécois
et les membres québécois du parti
conservateur
non seulement ont déjà été partant pour
ça mais savent qu'avec monsieur charest
il aurait une offre qui est quand même
plus modérées que celles qu'ils ont eues
avec par exemple indochine qui parlait
d' imposer d'un océan à l'autre des
pipelines à tout le monde ou avec eux
mêmes et renault trucks qui a joué un
peu dans ce film là alors et c'est le
parti donc ils font partie on n'est pas
au parti libéral ou npd ici ils
comprennent totalement des dynamiques et
ils savent aussi totalement que si la
partie et pour avoir de la crédibilité
sur la lutte aux changements climatiques
mais que monsieur charest pour devenir
chef il peut pas fermer la porte à ce
genre de démarche là c'est tombe bien
pour lui parce que la guerre en ukraine
est en train de changer j'ai la
conversation là dessus je vous dis pas
que ça veut dire que gnl québec et tous
et énergie est vont sortir de leur tombe
mais c'est lui permet quand même de
s'inscrire dans ceux des voleurs mais
monsieur trudeau on avait dit je ferme
pas la porte déjà dit que on pourrait
envoyer plus gaz naturel le pétrole vers
l'europe en fait pas sur un en voyant
cela en asie et dans le moment on en a
pas de débouchés vers l'europe alors
quelque part il y est chanceux oui le
contexte jonatha lui donne des airs
qu'un argumentaire pour pas avoir l'air
d'un autre siècle sur la question des
oléoducs là
absolument et oublions pas un fait
important dans les prochaines prochaines
semaines soit d'ici au 3 juin pour la
vente des cartes de membre et ensuite du
retrait au 10 septembre pour l'élection
jean charest n'a pas convaincre les
canadiens de ces de la justesse de ses
déceptions ce sont les membres du parti
conservateur qui l'a convaincu et en ce
sens ce que ce soit ici au québec ou
ailleurs dans les autres provinces pour
bien des gens ça va sonner comme la
musique à leurs oreilles et là où il
peut peut-être faire une différence par
rapport à une méfiance qui règne autour
engendré entre autres dans l'ouest c'est
qu'un acte mais je pense que ces propos
ils sont authentiques à jean charest il
rappelait quand 92 à riom lorsque on en
était mon premier belge balbutiements de
la sensibilisation aux changements
climatiques il avait amené l'industrie
avec lui il veut travailler que
l'industrie pour réduire l'empreinte
organiser une transition davantage en
douceur et je pense qu'il sera capable
de vendre cette idée là habillé déjà
prévoit l'entrée d'un camp vers une
enquête milite michel ouais il faut
faire quand même attention à ce que
monsieur charest dit parce que
il dit souvent ce qu'ils pensent que les
gens veulent entendre quand on lui a
posé la question sur le pipeline a dit
oui ce très intéressant en autant qu'il
y ait de l'acceptabilité sociale et
environnementale
je suppose que les membres du parti
conservateur ont dû demander de préciser
son opinion est ce que ça veut dire que
si par exemple à québec françois legault
comme il dit depuis deux trois ans parce
que monsieur legault aussi était
d'accord avec un pipeline cas était dans
l'opposition mais maintenant il dit s'il
n'ya pas d'acceptabilité sociale alors
là monsieur charest y de deux choses
l'une où il vaut dix rebelles houthis
pas de ma faute le québec en veut pas on
n'en a pas ou on va faire comme monsieur
léché et monsieur otto l'avait proposé
on va forcer les on va utiliser pouvoir
au gouvernement fédéral pour forcer un
passage voir ce soir monsieur charest
soit plus clair qu est-ce qui a dit
jusqu'à présent très bien autres
autre question il a été libéré s'amusant
parce que dans son mythique vers est une
évidence et au québec dans son
communiqué dit je vous cite là je n'ai
pas à l'écran mais en 98 et il quitte la
politique fédérale pour diriger la seule
coalition fédéraliste et s'opposer au
souverain d s'il est élu premier
ministre du québec dont le mot libéral
damas où il se retrouve pas dans le
communiqué est-ce que aux yeux des
certains militants conservateurs
jonathan vacances avec vos tours de
table le fait qu'il a été premier
ministre libéral est ce que c'est un
poids
bon il devra il devra essayer de sang de
s'en détacher je parle pas
nécessairement au québec parce que je
pense qu'au québec on est davantage un
lien qui la dynamique qui fait en sorte
qu'une personne libéral au provincial
pee très bientôt conservatrice au
fédéral mais on voit que des jeux ses
adversaires tentent de lui de lui coller
cette étiquette l'hôte d'un libéral ou
même titre que justin trudeau les et
c'est pour ça que déjà dans quelques
entrevues que monsieur chaoui raccordés
et dans des messages ont commencé à
circuler il veut vraiment expliquer ce
dépeinte comme étant un vrai
conservateur pas nécessairement ce qu'on
appelle un red tory conservateur rouge
mais vraiment un conservateur et définir
ce que ce qui est ce que ce qu'est pour
lui milk un conservateur mais assurément
il sera talonné avec ce tout au long de
la campagne la fiscalité et les finances
publiques entre michel davy
charest il va devoir vivre avec sans
passer avec tout son passé y compris
celui d'ancien chef du parti libéral
écoutez vous l'avez suivi en campagne
patrice comme moi les valeurs libérales
il nous brandissait le petit livre rouge
de claude ryan il ya des gens parmi ses
adversaires qui vont lui rappeler toutes
ces déclarations là et il ya des limites
monsieur charest de direz vous un
libéral et un conservateur dans le fond
c'est un peu la même affaire non pour
pour les gens la frange dure du parti
conservateur
c'est pas la même affaire alors oui je
pense que ça va être un caillou - bureau
je pense que d'autres que la question du
financement par exemple des partis
politiques que j'ai rivalisé avec un
caillou dans son soulier chantal on
imagine à peu près au ciment claude ryan
un congrès du parti libéral pierre
trudeau
applaudissant médicaux ou jean charest
un congrès du parti libéral
avec justin trudeau applaudissant justin
trudeau là dessus en ontario au québec
c'est quand même des deux polos dans
cette course là on fait la différence
mais moi j'ai l'impression que ce qui
nuit le plus à jean-charles époque qui
est allé un peu gamer sur wii le canada
c'est qui a été premier ministre du
québec et pour la base militante ou une
bonne partie de la base militante du
parti conservateur fédéral c'est un
grand défaut
michel vous avez parlé de ces questions
de financement dont celle enquête
machuret n'existe plus r- jamais
d'accusations criminelles va mais des
gens continuent à dire il aurait dû être
plus prudent dans le financement
sectoriel en trop qui l'a poussée qui
existe est partout mais qui a poussé
peut-être plus fort est-ce que ça je
conseille vous michel certains est ce
que c'est un réel problème ou ne pas
être pire que ça déjà été pour lui cette
question là on y est
ça dépend où je vous dirais je pense pas
que l'atlantique ou dans l'ouest on
fasse le grand code de la commission
charbonneau ou encore que monsieur
pallier un vautour sortir cela c'est
bien évident mais il est certain qu'au
québec salle est paul il ya le sondage
abacus sur deux jours qui disait que 47
% des québécois ont une mauvaise image
de monsieur charest et 20% une bonne
image mais là faut 20 % de ces à peu
près de votre conservateurs au québec un
peu plus il ya beaucoup de chemin à
faire d'eux les gens ont pu oublier ça
c'est pas parce qu'il a été
l'enquète machuret a été abandonnée que
les gens ne se souviennent pas de la
commission charbonneau ne se souviennent
pas des ministres à 100000 ne se
souviennent pas des déclarations des
gens d'affaires qui ont dit bah écoutez
on nous disait que si on cotise pas
caisse du parti on n'avait pas de
contrat c'est encore dans l'air tout
seul jonathan
je reviens encore un élément jean
charest dans les prochains mois ne pas
convaincre l'ensemble de l'électorat ce
sont des militants qu'il doit convaincre
et si je pense à la position au québec
on a l'impression que les yeux déjà
d'une base conservatrice et ajouter à
cela tous les militants libéraux
provinciaux qui sont en manque d'
enthousiasme d'être entichée d'un chef
j'étais là lorsque jean charest a perdu
ou congrès de 2008 je me trompe ou
philippe couillard il avait volé le show
beau spectacle à philippe couillard et
je parle constamment des militants
libéraux dans les dernières semaines qui
ont hâte de faire campagne pour lui
qu'ils ont de l'est puis donc oui jean
charest pour la réaliser il faut pas
oublier ben faut pas oublier qu'il ya
encore bien des gens qu'il aime au
québec même si y en a que ça surprend
encore ils écrivent ainsi les libéraux
c'est vrai tous les anciens libéraux qui
ont fait campagne avec jean charest l'a
dû littéralement
mais vous avez remarqué que madame
anglade est nettement moins enthousiaste
c'est un oui mais les autres changent
pour pour pour lui faire dire qu'il
fallait abandonner ma chérie non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya des
libéraux qui sont moins enthousiastes
que
que la vielle garde dont chahtane deux
choses d'abord madame angulaire de
raison de s'inquiéter parce que
plusieurs de ses militants sont plus
enthousiastes pour le vote du 12
septembre que pour celui d'octobre au
québec c'est un très bon signe pour
quelqu'un qui voudrait gagner une
élection mais ce qui est aussi important
pour jean charest c'est que parmi les
gens qui de la deux c'est des gens qui
vivent dans des comptes est orphelin
pour le parti conservateur fédéral des
circonscriptions qui sont chanceuses
quand il ya trente membres du parti
conservateur et ces gens là veulent
vraiment recruter des membres proches
alliés c'est le seul dans le moment qui
a une voix aussi large au québec c'est
la deuxième province qui va opposer le
plus lourd à condition de recruter 100
membres dont on n'est pas dans cent
mille 100 membres par circonscriptions
au québec pour avoir le deuxième plus
important poids avec patrick brown qui
fait la même chose ça pourrait donner
des résultats surprenants loi 21 il l'a
répété
mais il expliqué à mario dumont ce matin
doivent interjetté qu'on devait pas
jeter quand je n'ai pas voulu aller dans
le sens là après le rapport bon si on
connaît l'histoire et je suis content je
vais rester contre mais là il dit le si
j'étais premier volet du canada il y
aurait une participation fédérale
devant la cour suprême michel david sait
ce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
l'aider ou qui peut lui nuire bah c'est
la position monsieur trudeau en fait et
bien honnêtement peu près tout premier
ministre du canada je pense aurait le
même le même réflexe je défends je
défends la constitution canadienne en
fait la charte des droits kidari
conditions alors non je pense pas que ça
soit sept principales preuves jonathas
et c'est pas un facteur
il ya quand même quelque chose de
surprenant parce qu'ils aimeraient que
cette pulsion le serait peu populaire au
québec effectivement qu'elle est
analogue à celle de de justin trudeau
moi ce qui me frappe c'est que lorsqu'on
parlait du schisme entre les députés
conservateurs québécois et le reste du
caucus dans les exemples que les députés
nous citait il y avait l'absence de
compréhension de leurs collègues sur le
bien fondé de la pluie la loi 21 au
québec or le finalement ils sont
derrière un caddie doxa va dire
essentiellement la même chose que le
premier ministre canadien et là
soudainement soudainement comme jean
charest sans l'identifier comme le
sauveur on dirait que ça passe mais
reste que c'est pourtant une potion qui
déplaît son caucus québécois
conservateur
chatel
on imagine nous on espère pour monsieur
charrier qui a fait ses devoirs auprès
de ses partisans là dessus au québec
parce qu'effectivement
pour avoir patrick brown dans son camp
un moment donné patrick brown c'est le
maire de brampton que lancé le mouvement
des grandes villes canadiennes qui
devrait financer la cause des
adversaires de la loi 21 et il va
peut-être pas en faire un thème de
campagne mais ça va être quelque part un
paysage dans le camp de pierre poilievre
il ya un certain nombre de députés qui
sont du même a dit donc au sein de la
course c'est pas un sujet de division et
on présume monsieur charest a fait de la
politique longtemps on présume que faire
ses devoirs et puis qui sait assurer
auprès d'alain gaillard d'internautes
que on pouvait vivre avec cette position
pour le parti il faudra voir mais là on
a le temps tu repars les mille fois mais
pour le faudra voir sur un schisme ou
s'ils ont reçu ce complot va être
tellement fort qu il va trouver
difficile de réconcilier tout le monde
mais ce qui va changer par rapport à la
dernière course indéniablement c'est que
les médias vont s'y intéresser
chantal tour de table c'est une course
et oui nous allons suivre cette fois ci
ben oui regardez nous là
les compteurs des coûts j'avoue qu'on
vous d'ailleurs c'est pas mal plus
épidermique et surtout du point de vue
francophone mais pas seulement du point
de vue francophone mais si les médias
vont s'y intéresser pour une autre
raison
dans le cycle normal de politique
canadienne on arrive vers la fin du
règne libéral c'est des tranches de dix
ans donc la personne qui vont être élus
cette fois ci a beaucoup plus de chances
de devenir premier ministre contre
justin trudeau quelqu'un d'autre ou que
les deux précédents alors oui évidemment
et en plus on est dans un moment dans
l'histoire où les enjeux politiques
réelles le changement climatique que la
guerre c'est pas exactement la même
chose que de se disputer sur le registre
contrôle des amateurs jonathan
chaque course à la chefferie amène son
lot de pots cassés mais lieu dans ce cas
ci c'est carrément l'avenir du parti qui
est en jeu c'est ce qui fait consensus
moi j'ai l'impression que la fracture
elle est inévitable reste à voir à quel
point leurs fractures et qui sera le
mieux placé pour recoller les pots
cassés puis essayer de garder le parti à
flot en vue de la prochaine élection
celle david oui les gens et je parle pas
des conservateurs le je parle des
observateurs la population générale aime
les beaux combats politiques et il est
clair qu'avec jean charest d'un côté et
pierre poilievre de l'autre leur vous
avez un vrai choc alors c'est certain
que la même pour les amateurs de sport
politique simplement là ça va être
passionnant j'avais été passionnant été
très intéressant chantal michel jonathan
merci à très bientôt au revoir en ce
moment pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh